Chris Pratt is busy running from
dinosaurs man London currently were back
in production on Jurassic world Dominion
Pratt is back at work but took the 11
hour flight home to LA to spend the 4th
of July weekend with pregnant wife
Catherine Jurassic world Dominion
resumes today but Pratt is expected to
be finished in time to return to LA for
the birth something I like to say to the
cast members before we start production
is we are gonna have our names and faces
on something that will outlive us the
studio is going to extreme lengths to
keep the entire cast and crew safe
spending a reported five million dollars
on everything from 150 hand-washing
stations to nightly antiviral fogging of
the sets I appreciate that the folks who
are making drastic are doing it you know
with their eyes wide open and getting
all of the information from you know the
folks who are really at the front lines
and really understand what we're facing
here kovat 19 is a severe lung infection
that attacks the lungs and could cause
lasting damage the og Jurassic Park cast
is back for the three cool Laura Dern
and Jeff Goldblum have been health
advocates during the lockdown and Sam
Neill recently dropped some hints about
his role while filming this skit was
Stephen Fry I've been training I think
you know getting fit oh he's awesome
dinosaurs talked about it of course but
I have to fight Chris Pratt don't Jeff
Goldblum at the same time I win there
the cast will be joined on set by Terry
who won the chance to get eaten by a
dino as part of the all-in challenge
Chris zoom bomb Terry and his family
with the good news we have some really
cool ideas for how to kill you in a
memorable and exciting way this is crazy
[Music]